the number 36 is three times as large as
12.
write this comparison as a
multiplication equation so they're
saying that the number 36 so type 36 is
equal to
3 3
times
12. and i use this little star thing
let's see if i would have put an x there
would that have worked as well no they
would have viewed that as 3x so if i put
this so to get this little star thing
which is normally when you're typing on
a computer how you show multiplication
that to get that you have to press shift
and
shift and the number eight and it also
sometimes shows up on a numeric keypad
but by doing that i was able to show
multiplication so this could be read as
36 is equal to
3 times 12 or 36 is three times as large
as 12. let's check our answer
got it right let's do a couple more of
these
we can compare the numbers 4 and 20
using addition by saying that 20 is 16
more than 4. fair enough that's right we
could also compare 4 and 20 using
multiplication
fill in the blank correctly to compare
the numbers 4 and 20 using
multiplication so they're saying 20 is
blank times as large as 4.
well we know that 4 times 5 is 20 or
that 5 times 4 is 20. so 20 is five
times as large as four if i take four
five times i'll get to 20. so let me
check my answer
there you go
let's do one more
the number six is three times as large
as two write this comparison as a
multiplication equation so once again we
could write that six
is equal to two and then i press shift
and the number eight to get that times
symbol that little asterisk snowflake
looking thing
two times 3. so i could write it like
that or i could write 2 times 3 is equal
to 6. either of those would be
completely valid things to say so here
i'm saying 6 is well i could say
actually i'd like to say it this way i'd
like to say 3 times as large as 2 i
think that's a little bit more fun so
this is exactly six is three times as
large as two
and we're done